Please welcome Bridget Moynahan!
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Hi.
Oh my gosh.
I've loved you in so many different iterations
and films and movies and characters,
but gosh, let's kick it off with Natasha.
I mean, "Sex and the City."
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
You're so incredible as Natasha.
It's like, how did you approach playing her?
What was it like filming it?
Just give me the goods.
Okay, so I remember going on the set and thinking,
oh my god, I have no idea what I'm doing.
This huge set, it was like
in motion.
I had to just jump in like double judge
and hope to god I didn't trip and fall
and get fired all in one day.
But it worked out.
I mean-
It worked out.
Clearly it worked out, you became
an iconic representation.
And then there's "And Just Like That..."
and Natasha returns.
What was that like?
(audience applauds)
Oh boy, was I thrilled to get that phone call
and be asked back.
And you know, there was one scene where Natasha
was up in a window and she's looking down,
and Carrie and the girls are looking up.
And I have to say, there was a bunch of takes
where I was a fan and I'm just watching them,
and I'm like, oh my god, the shoes,
oh my god, the dresses, oh my god, they're back.
This is so exciting.
And I kind of think I really needed that for my soul
after two years of being in COVID and sweatpants,
and just kind of slothing around,
and I needed that fashion and that color
and that pizzazz again, it really made me feel so good.
I kind of feel that way about you too.
Every single day, you show up in the most amazing outfits,
prints, vests, everything.
You're like a daily "Sex and the City" fashionista.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
So, thank you.
(Bridget laughs)
Thank you, Bridget.
I take that as such a compliment,
so, thank you, I appreciate that.
(audience applauds)
Now, is it true that your son finally watched "Coyote Ugly"
and you're in the room?
How did that go?
Yes.
So yeah, I think it was the anniversary,
20th anniversary maybe of "Coyote Ugly."
And he saw me dancing on the bar in those
sassy leather pants that wrapped up the crotch
and he...
"Mom, you are so wild."
And I was like, hmm, yeah, that's just the script.
(laughs) Okay, well, this season of "Blue Bloods",
I'm so excited to announce and discuss, you are directing.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Did you always think like, one day, when I'm ready,
I would love to do this?
I think I grew into it.
I think that people always encouraged me,
because of whatever that they saw in me to do it.
And over the years,
we've really had a few women come through
from different departments
and earn their wings in the directing portion of it.
And I've watched them go up through the ranks,
and they've always suggested, always supported me.
And so I finally got the opportunity and I had,
I mean, I just almost started crying when I saw that photo.
I had such an incredible experience
and it feels really,
it feels really great to take on this new challenge
and go to this next level and this next step.
And it's a first.
And I just turned 50,
and it just feels really good to be doing something new
and have a new challenge in this next decade.
Congratulations on that, truly.
Thank you.
May we all find the courage to take it higher.
And everybody, be sure to watch "Blue Bloods"
Fridays at 10:00 PM Eastern on CBS.
Bridget, thank you so much.
(upbeat bright music)